So now that we've built
out the two models,
let's compare them side by side using
the model comparison tool yet again.
So how we do this is we first bring in
the union tool, and connect the model
objects from both our stepwise and
our decision tree models together.
Then what we do as we bring
in our model comparison tool
where the union model objects
go into the M or model side.
And the validation data set
goes into the D or data side.
And just like in all of our other
models, we're going to name what is
a positive class we want to
have in that target variable.
Which is going to be the yes responses.
After this, I'm going to bring in
a browse tool after this R output and
run the workflow.
What I'm expecting as the results
is to see exactly the same thing in
the model comparison tool from our
individual models but now side by side.
And the whole reason I am doing that
is it's just easier to compare the two
different models against each other
side by side rather than looking at two
different windows.
So let's go examine those outputs now.
So the first thing like we did before
is we're going to look at that
accuracy report.
And as you can see the logistic plus
stepwise model has a 2% greater
accuracy than the decision tree model.
But let's look at some of the other
items that are found within this report.
The confusion matrix is the same
as what we saw before so
we're going to just skip over this part.
Let's go over to the games chart
found in the diagnostic plots.
So what the games chart is showing
me is the true response rate
on the y-axis as compared to
the rate of positive predictions.
So what I simply look for
is which of the two models,
the quiz stepwise represented in orange,
or the decision tree redeemer
represented in blue,
reaches the top the quickest.
So this is split into different deciles,
but the only thing you really need to
note here is which model
reaches the top the quickest.
And which model is
overall highest the most.
And what I'm able to see is that
the stepwise model from the logistic
regression is a little bit higher
than the decision tree model
in this experiment.
But as you can see, there's some
different diagnostic plots found within
here such as a lift chart, a precision
and recall curve, an ROC curve, etc..
I'm not going to go in depth on
any of these different types of
diagnostic plots.
But there are some notes to
how to interpret them and
what they actually might mean
down in the reading note section.
What I typically take is just the gain's
chart from this diagnostic plot section.
But looking at all of these, the
diagnostic plot, the confusion matrix,
the Fit and error measures,
overall accuracy, it looks like we have
two very good models on our hands.
And evidence shows that a logistic plus
stepwise model performs slightly better
in almost every category in test.
Therefore, it is the one that
I would choose to predict
who is likely to redeem deals
with future marketing campaigns.